guten abend hinein zu einem kurzen
nachrichten update von uns hier aus der
heute redaktion
wir beginnen mit cdu und csu vor der
bundestagswahl die unionsparteien wollen
sich heute auf ein gemeinsames
wahlprogramm verständigen
einige kernpunkte sind schon bekannt
absage an steuererhöhungen neue wege in
der rentenpolitik deutschland zu einem
klimaneutralen industrieland machen
in details hakt es aber noch es gibt
auch noch streitpunkte die csu etwa will
mehr mütter rente und wenn sich die
spitzen der parteien zu endgültigen
beratungen jetzt im moment in berlin
treffen dann bleibt auch die frage wie
einig treten armin laschet und markus
söder da auf begehen live nach berlin
zur mathis feldhoff genommen hatte
drehen wir ein bisschen inhaltlich
laschet ist ja angetreten mit dem
versprechen deutschland grundlegend zu
modernisieren wie viel ist davon im
programm zu lesen
naja sind 200 seiten die die cdu jetzt
die csu jetzt zusammen aufgeschrieben
haben tatsächlich ist der große aufbruch
der umbau von staat und bürokratie in
diesem programm nicht wirklich wieder zu
erkennen dieses programm atmet doch sehr
die bewältigung der finanziellen folgen
der pandemie
deshalb ist auch diese frage der mütter
rente nicht wirklich zu sagen länder
party
die csu will diese 3,8 milliarden für
die gleichstellung von müttern in der
rentenversicherung die cdu sagt das ist
schlicht nicht zu bezahlen und so wird
am ende das ähnlich sein wie immer die
cdu wird dieses nicht in das gemeinsame
wahlprogramm aufnehmen lassen und die
csu macht am ende ihr eigenes ding
die analyse in kurzform von mathis
feldhoff vielen dank dafür
ihr wahlprogramm beschlossen hat jetzt
die linkspartei nach zweitägigen online
parteitag und mit klarer mehrheit
ihr credo umverteilung steuern rauf für
reiche und unternehmen dafür ein
mindestlohn von 13 euro und eine vier
tage arbeitswoche bei vollem
lohnausgleich
was die linke außerdem will mehr
geschlossenheit in den eigenen reihen
und mitregieren andrea das spitzenduo
der linken für den wahlkampf janine
wissler und dietmar bartsch deutlich
bemüht um positive bilder denn das bild
dass ihre partei in den letzten wochen
ab
ab war nicht gut innerparteiliche
richtungsstreit bei schlechten
umfragewerten
deshalb geht es jetzt darum die
gemeinsamkeiten voranzustellen und die
menschen zu überzeugen dass eine starke
linke mehr soziale gerechtigkeit in
diesem land bedeutet rückenwind für die
parteispitze knapp 88 prozent der
delegiertenstimmen heute für das
wahlprogramm
darin unter anderem ein mindestlohn von
13 euro mindesteinkommen und
mindestrente von je 1200 euro und das
ende aller auslandseinsätze der
bundeswehr zur finanzierung der korona
kosten fordert die linke außerdem eine
abgabe für vermögen ab 2 millionen euro
einige der reichsten männer dieses
landes sind die besitzer von
einzelhandelsketten deren gewinn und
damit auch deren vermögen ist im letzten
jahr noch mal weiter gestiegen aber am
ende soll die kassiererin die oft mit
niedriglohn abgespeist werden die kosten
für die krise tragen das ist überhaupt
nicht akzeptabel und das werden wir in
diesem wahlkampf zum thema machen
die linke zeigt sich kämpferisch und
regierungs bereit einen antrag die
partei auf die oppositionsrolle
festzulegen lehnte der parteitag ab
aktuell liegt die linke bei 6 bis 7
prozent bei der korona zahlen geht es
mit den positiven trend weiter zum
ersten mal seit anfang september liegt
die inzidenz in allen deutschen städten
und kreisen wieder unter 50
das robert koch institut meldet binnen
eines tages 842 neuinfektionen das sind
6 147 weniger als vergangenen sonntag 16
menschen starben innerhalb von 24
stunden
die sieben tage incidents sinkt weiter
auf jetzt 8,8 dramatisch dagegen die
zahlen in brasilien das land zählt
inzwischen mehr als 500.000 corona tote
täglich werden mehr als 80.000
neuinfektionen gemeldet
im ganzen land haben deshalb am
wochenende hunderttausende gegen die
korona politik von präsident jerry ball
so nahe protestiert sie werfen ihm vor
die pandemie zu verharmlosen und fordern
mehr tempo beim impfen in frankreich
heute die erste runde der regional- und
deportes wahlen ein wichtiger letzter
stimmungstest vor der
präsidentschaftswahl
frühjahr 2022 laut umfragen könnten die
rechtspopulisten von marine le pen
stärkste kraft werden auch weil die
wahlbeteiligung so gering ist wie seit
jahrzehnten nicht nur rund ein viertel
der franzosen hat bis zum nachmittag
abgestimmt es läuft für deutschland bei
der em einen rückstand fulminant gedreht
am ende 4 2 gegen den amtierenden
europameister portugal und eine
erkenntnis löws mannschaft ist wieder
eine mannschaft und kann doch noch
gewinnen und feiern sowie das land heiko
klassen mit mehr dazu der alltag ist
zurück im deutschen mannschaftsquartier
und doch dürfte der alles andere als
alltägliche fußball abend zuvor spuren
hinterlassen haben spuren beim dfb team
das nach dem 4 2 gegen portugal nun
endlich wieder mit voller überzeugung an
die eigene stärke glauben kann und
spuren auch bei den texten endlich
wieder aus dem häuschen sein durften bei
diesem mitreißenden spiel das buch wie
ist das schön so tatsächlich lange nicht
mehr zu sehen
[Applaus]
die fans begeistert die mannschaft
begeistert herren mit mut leidenschaft
und ganz viel herz spielen für mein land
ich darf mir mein land repräsentieren
wenn man da nicht sich für das schürze
reis und alles reine haut dann dann weiß
ich auch nicht weiter ich glaube diese
energie die kommt von alleine und mit so
viel energie kann es ruhig weitergehen
der sommer ist ja eh schon da fehlt nur
noch das märchen über nordrhein
westfalen ist in der nacht eine
gewitterfront mit starkregen gezogen in
köln legte das unwetter eine u bahn lahm
gleisanlagen und tunnel abschnitte waren
nach heftigen regenfällen überflutet
das galt auch für mehrere straßen tunnel
die feuerwehr musste zu mehr als 240
einsätzen ausrücken haupt sich
hauptsächlich wegen vollgelaufener
keller
wir merken schon es lohnt sich den
himmel im auge zu behalten aktuell gibt
es eine warnung vor schwerem gewitter in
baden württemberg und morgen sieht so
aus im nordwesten viel regen mit
gewittern überall sonst erst mal
freundlich später dann aber wieder
gewitter das ganze bei 16 bis 32 grad
so fiel in der kürze von uns hier danke
für ihr interesse
ich wünsche ihnen einen sehr angenehmen
fußballer
[Musik]